We already look into the rate of change of the number of infectious persons.
It was a constant times the number of infectious persons times the number of susceptible persons.
If this is the number of persons per day that move from susceptible to infectious,
the same number has to get lost from the susceptible compartment.
So the rate of change of the number of susceptible persons has to be minus the same quantity,
and then there's the second effect mainly that people recover.
We've already looked at that term.
This is the increase of the number of recovered persons per time.
If this number of persons is added to the recovered compartment each day,
we have to subtract it from the infectious compartment as well.
We have to subtract it from the infectious compartment because these persons leave
the infectious compartment and join the recovered compartment.
This completes the equations of the SIR model. Obviously, this is a very rough model.
In particular, as the numbers that we are dealing with here are not integer numbers,
in real life they should be say 1,000 or 1,000 at 1 or 1,000 at 2 persons, but with these equations,
we're dealing with say 1,000.1, 2 , 3, 4, 5 persons.
These equations can only make sense for large numbers of persons so that the fractional part
can be ignored, but if these numbers are large, the numerical constants that we're using here
may for instance be used to model influenza.